>> Jesse: THE MAYOR WHO IS BUSY
MAKING TIK TOK VIDEOS WHILE HER
CITY BURNS IS NOW DEMANDING A
RAISE.
♪♪
>> Jesse: MAYOR LIGHTFOOT
PROPOSING A CITY ORDINANCE THAT
WOULD GIVE HERSELF A 5% PAY
BUMP.
ADDING ABOUT $10,000 TO HER
CUSHY SALARY.
CRIME IS UP 37% IN THE WINDY
CITY SINCE LAST YEAR AND A
HANDFUL OF BIG BUSINESSES HAVE
FLED.
DANA, FROM A COMMUNICATIONS
PERSPECTIVE, IS NOW THE TIME TO
BE DEMANDING A RAISE?
>> Dana: I THINK PROBABLY NOT.
THE SITUATION IS THE CITY
COUNCIL IS GETTING A RAISE SO
WHY CAN'T I GET IN ON THIS DEAL?
IT'S A 5% RAISE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO GET BACK AND FORTH ON
OUR COMMUTE.
ALSO, WHARLT THE MURDER RATE?
SOME OF THESE CITIES, IT WOULD
BE INTERESTING IF YOU CAN FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO TIE THE SALARY OF A
PUBLIC OFFICIAL TO THINGS THAT
MATS TORE A CITY.
LIKE A MURDER RATE.
IF THE MURDER RATE GOES TO X --
LIKE INCENTIVE PAY FOR DOING
BETTER FOR THE CITIZENS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IN CHICAGO HAS
GONE BETTER THAT SHE WOULD
DESERVE A RAISE.
>> Jesse: SHE'S GOING TO CASH
OUT AFTER SHE'S MAYOR.
SHE WILL BE MAKING A MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AT SOME BOARD OR
WHATEVER.
CAN'T SHE WAIT?
DOES SHE NEED THE EXTRA $10,000
RIGHT NOW?
>> Greg: THIS ONLY WAY THIS
INCOMPETENT PERSON CAN GET A
RAISE IF SHE AWARDS HERSELF ONE,
THIS IS HOW POLITICS ATTRACTSES
INCOMPETENT PEOPLE.
AS LONG AS SHE CAN WIN ELECTIONS
THROUGH INTIMIDATION, THIS IS
HER LIFE.
SHE'S BLACK, LESBIAN.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU KNOW ABOUT HER?
HOW MANY PEOPLE WERE SHOT AND
KILLED WHEN SHE DOES THESE TIK
TOK VIDEOS?
GOOGLE LORI LIGHTFOOT AFTER THIS
AND YELP HER REVIEW OF THE LIMO
COMPANY.
YOU CAN SEE HER.
SHE'S AN AWFUL PERSON.
>> Geraldo: GIVE US A HUNT.
>> Dana: IT'S TERRIBLE.
>> Greg: SHE ACCUSED THE DRIVER
OF USING HER BATHROOM.
IT'S 1 OF THE FUNNIEST THINGS
YOU'LL READ.
>> Jeanine: THE COMPANY SAYS WE
KNOW WHEN THE DRIVER IS IN THE
CAR.
THE DRIVER NEVER LEFT THE CAR.
YOU'RE CRAZY.
THEY GAVE 20 REASONS WHY.
SHE'S NOT ONLY TONE DEAF, SHE'S
SELFISH.
THIS WOMAN IS SELFISH.
SHE'S TALKING ABOUT DANCING AND
SINGING AND MAKING MORE MONEY
AND SAYING I'LL ONLY TALK TO YOU
IF YOU'RE A BLACK REPORTER.
I MEAN, SHAME ON THIS WOMAN.
VIOLENT CRIME HAS INCREASED 37%.
MOTOR VEHICLE THEFT 74%.
IF YOU HAVE A CAR THAT RUNS,
CHANCES ARE THEY'RE GOING TO
STEAL IT FROM YOU, THIS WOMAN
DESERVES NOTHING.
I DON'T THINK SHE SHOULD BE PAID
ANYTHING.
FORGET ABOUT TYING HER SALARY TO
THE MURDER RATE.
JUST TIE HER SALARY TO THE FACT
THAT PEOPLE -- BUSINESSES ARE
LEAVING THE CITY.
McDONALD'S --
>> Dana: BOEING.
>> Jeanine: A BUNCH OF THEM THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT.
SHE'S AN EMBARRASSMENT.
THEY SHOULD RECALL HER.
>> Jesse: I HAVE A PROPOSAL,
GERALDO.
PUBLIC OFFICIALS SHOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO VOTE THEMSELVES PAY
RAISES WHILE THEY'RE ON THE JOB.
YOU CAN VOTE A PAY RAISE FOR
THAT POSITION, BUT IT DOESN'T
KICK IN UNTIL THE FOLLOWING
POLITICIAN TAKES YOUR SEAT.
>> Greg: I DON'T HAVE A
PARTICULAR PROBLEM WITH THAT,
JESSE.
GOING BACK TO THE DANCING.
IT'S A GREAT IDEA TO TIE
POLITICIANS PERFORMANCE WITH
COLD STONE OBJECTIVE THIS MANY
MURDERS.
>> Jesse: NOBODY WOULD RUN.
>> Geraldo: IN HER DEFENSE, THIS
SALARY INCREASE WOULD PUT HER ON
A PAR TO RAHM EMANUEL, THE MAYOR
SOME YEARS AGO, EIGHT YEARS.
IT GIVES HER PARODY THERE.
>> Jesse:RY WAS RAHM MAKING
MORE?
>> THEY DICTATE WHAT THEIR
SALARIES ARE.
>> Greg: HIS BROTHER IS HIS
AGENT.
>> Geraldo: THE RAISE IS CAPPED
AT 5%.
YOUR SOCIAL SECURITY, COST OF
LIVING BUMP IS MORE THAN 5%.
>> Jeanine: ISN'TS SHE
EMBARRASSED?
SHE'S DOING A TERRIBLE JOB
OBJECTIVELY.
>> Geraldo: I'M GOT GOING TO
DEFEND LORI LIGHTFOOT AND THE
MURDER RATE IN CHICAGO.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT'S A NATIONAL
DISGRAY.
IS IT HER FAULT?
>> Jeanine: YES.
LIKE DEFUND THE POLICE.
>> Geraldo: WHERE IS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- WHERE ARE THE